well Laos is clearing uh at the end of
prime minister's questions
um lots to discuss let's bring in our
political editor Beth Rigby I mean
there's first of all Beth is there's the
the to and fro between her and kirstmer
um but also quite crucially what appears
to be a Divergence of policy between her
and her Chancellor so it started off as
this the main story of this pmqs being
the exchanges between starmer and her
the the league of the opposition with
this kind of mix of mockery and contempt
for the Prime Minister who her part said
I am a fighter actually borrowing uh
Peter mandelson's line there but she was
really in fight in form there trying to
put in a good performance but the
bombshell in that chamber was her uh
response to a question on uplifting or
maintaining the pensions triple lot this
is when pensions rise in line uh with
inflation if that's the highest of three
uh three areas where you might lift it
by but essentially it's like will you
lift pensions will you up rate them with
inflation now Jeremy Hunt clearly said
on Monday that he would not commit to
this policy he said I'm not making any
specific commitments on spending until
October the 31st he explicitly ruled it
out and interviews me where I explicitly
asked he explicitly ruled it out in the
Commons the Prime Minister has stood up
there and has overruled her Chancellor
she has said in the comments that she it
was a Manifesto commitment it was a
pledge she made when she was trying to
be leader and she has said clearly there
on the floor of the commons I am
committed to uprighting with inflation
pensions now there's a couple of things
going on there one she's facing a back
bench Rebellion on this issue a number
of MPS have already got out come out
publicly saying this was a Manifesto
commitment it was a promise you may made
when you're a leader you cannot undo it
so she knew she had a political battle
but the issue is is that she brought
Jeremy hunting in order to study the
ship calm the markets he took control of
tax and spend decisions quite clearly on
Monday and the Prime Minister there at
the dispatch box has publicly overruled
him now I've got so many questions on
that does he agree with her if he
doesn't how will he react will this
unnerve the markets that the prime
minister is again making policy on the
hoof that she might have to you turn on
she's done another u-turn on a U-turn
and so the reason that this is
politically really interesting is that
she needs Jeremy Hunt
in order to have any credibility at all
of staying in number 10 and she has just
publicly overruled him in the Commons
and I'm very interested to see how
Jeremy Hunt and the treasury react to
that now maybe he was fine with that but
that was not what he said 48 hours ago
and hasn't the story of this government
in terms of the market turmoil and the
voter dissatisfaction being about saying
one thing doing another saying one thing
doing another and the Prime Minister has
just done that again when Jeremy Hunt
said I'm making no specific tax and
spend commitments until the fiscal
statement on October the 31st she just
blew that up well indeed and that
contradicted something she'd said about
no more spending cuts last week but
again he absolutely ruled out three days
later on so if you are that's exactly
right Jade so if you're a conservative
MP you have a prime minister that says
things that the dispatch box is there
any credibility at all in what she says
why is she undermining what was set up
in order to be
an attempt to stabilize things and I
think that there's a question for me
certainly like was that an agreed
decision James cleverly how foreign
secretary was on Sky news this morning
refusing to commit to that policy and
that's another element of this chain if
you're a prime minister and you're very
embattled as she clearly is you need
your cabinet to back you because if one
of them decides that they're going to
stand down that's when it could trigger
flood of resignations and that's what
happened you remember with Boris Johnson
Sajid Javid went where she sooner went
and that was the Tipping Point and the
herd moved and then he was gone by
when's what Thursday morning that week
okay so the question I've got is James
cleverley has just been contradicted
hours later by the Prime Minister Jeremy
Hunt has just been contradicted by the
Prime Minister did she get an agreement
or is she just trying to overrule her
Chancellor and if she is what's the
backlash going to be I don't know the
answers it's just happened but my
analysis would be that that could be a
real hot potato for her let's see what
I'm very interested to see how Jeremy
Hunt reacts to that that's